today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
hey welcome everybody um one of the
things we're going to spend some time
talking about today are the recent
protests
and unrest and violence and the way that
uh people have been trying to take
advantage of that violence and unrest
but before we even do that one of the
things i want to talk about is this
broader context
in which donald trump is running for
president
as if someone else has been president
for the last
four years and that's just one
aspect of what i want to focus in on
today and and that particular aspect is
really unlike anything we've seen
in the modern political era for
presidents running for re-election
most presidents have run for re-election
very
clearly on i've been in charge for four
years
and we're going to get another four
years that will be similar
to the last four and that's good donald
trump is doing something very very
different and that's what i want to talk
about now before we get we get into that
i guess it's important to mention
i'm leaving a lot out of this analysis
uh
in terms of things that donald trump is
doing of course this has been one of the
most dishonest presidencies the lie
count is off the charts and donald trump
has been doing a lot of lying
to justify his re-election as well okay
on the
issues donald trump has failed to
deliver on a bunch of different campaign
issues
the wall replacing the health care
system on and on
and on but there's a reason that i want
to focus in on this particular aspect
because it relates to
the sort of gaslighty nature
of the campaign as well as the
um intellectually compromised element of
donald trump's electorate which is that
donald trump is framing his re-election
campaign
as if you need to choose him instead of
what we've had
for the last four years and
unfortunately it's
working on a lot of people as evidenced
by some of the interviews when you go to
these rallies that donald trump has been
doing
the rnc etc and the language that trump
is using suggests somebody else has been
in charge
for the last four years and in order to
fix
that donald trump must be elected
when you look at this phrase make
america great again
again that is predicated
on the implicit understanding that trump
won in 2016 and for a while he was great
and he made
america great again and then that sort
of fell apart
including with coronavirus and the
economy
and now we need to elect trump in order
to make america great again again
because it's almost like trump hasn't
been the one in charge for the last six
or seven
months we have to put trump back in
power
to fix problems that were actually
created during donald trump's presidency
as if he was not in charge during that
time this
is going to be a big factor in our
discussion about
protests and unrest donald trump
has been talking about the mass protests
and the unrest
with the framing of democrat cities as
he says
run by far left mayors anarchists or
anarchists as he calls them
marxists and others the reality is that
it's trump himself who has generated the
unrest
we didn't have unrest like this when joe
biden was vice
president for eight years and i'm going
to come back to that in a little bit
uh there's been donald trump's
mishandling of so many issues
but trump is running as if other people
have been in charge
for the last six months and in order to
get things
back under control you need to elect
donald trump now of course
any thinking person would realize trump
is saying
things are out of control with me as
president
so re-elect me to fix it but
of course why would we do that why
wouldn't trump
just be able to get things under control
now in other words
why is he saying that only in his second
term will he be able to get these things
under control
and of course when you realize that he's
been what's been generating the unrest
and the discontent
the entire argument falls apart in in
some sense
trump is almost running against himself
but
putting in joe biden as a proxy to take
the hit
for donald trump's own failings and i i
wish it weren't
the case there's really no way to say
this without offending some people
but his supporters that are eating it up
are eating it up in great part because
they
are intellectually compromised now some
of them know it's bs
but they want trump reelected for other
reasons and so they're just jumping on
the bandwagon but a lot of people are
actually falling for this stuff
now there's a few different thoughts
about why donald trump
is doing this one thought is that this
is some kind of four-dimensional chess
he's taking credit for successes but
painting the failings on joe biden or on
democratic mayors or whoever the case
may be
and it's all kind of uh calculated
to paint him as the underdog despite the
fact that he's the incumbent right we
could go into some kind of more complex
analysis the other explanation is way
simpler which is trump's a one-trick
pony
he doesn't know how to run as the
incumbent
and he is running the exact same
campaign
that he ran as the supposed political
outsider in 2016
he's just running the same campaign
ignoring the fact that he's been the
president for four years
we really have not seen anything like
this and it's preying upon
the most ignorant voters but that is not
a guarantee that it's going to fail to
work it very well
could succeed and this is why i've been
sounding the alarm now for several weeks
saying
we can't write off what to many of us
seem like
obviously terrible strategies as
ineffective
because it may work donald trump
genuinely expects that americans are
going to fall for this
and plenty of americans are falling for
it now
the other thing on top of this which we
have to remember
is that joe biden was sort of in charge
for eight years in other words when joe
biden was vice president
okay barack obama was the president but
we didn't have in obama and biden's
america
chaos and unrest the likes of which
donald trump is now preemptively
assigning to joe biden you had tea
partiers
who sometimes protested uh you you had
ferguson which was a very different
thing than what we have going on right
now
you certainly had shootings but that was
a gun problem which we have not fixed
but things were actually far more calm
during the era
in which joe biden was vice president to
the president of the united states
and so at even on the facts
you don't even have to hypothesize what
it would be like
if joe biden were president you can go
back and see what things were like when
joe biden was vice president and we're
going to get
into later on in the program why is it
that trump benefits from chaos and
unrest
you would think that if people were
thinking clearly they would say oh
if there's chaos and unrest while trump
is president
it doesn't make sense to vote for him
again to fix it we should vote for
someone else
that would be a logical assessment i'm
going to explain to you later on in the
program
uh why why that doesn't work or in other
words why donald trump does benefit
from the chaos and why he's trying to
incite it but before we go to that let's
talk about
the after effects of the republican
national convention
so uh we learned from a new abc news
ipsos poll
that donald trump's favorability has
actually
declined since the republican convention
by a little bit
now to understand why this is important
and then what the limits are
we should first talk a little bit about
what normally happens when there are
conventions so if you if you go back
many decades
um the way that it typically works is
the incumbent
party uh has their convention second
but regardless you see that whoever has
their convention first
gets a little bit of a bump in the
polling and favorability
and then the numbers settle back down
and then whoever goes second with their
convention gets a little bump in the
polling and favorability and then it
comes back down
and by the time we get into september
and debates
and then october and all of the things
that happen in the two months leading up
to an election
the effect of the conventions is
essentially sort of zeroed out things
return to the mean
that's the normal situation according to
a new poll
from abc news and ipsos donald trump has
not even gotten the bump in favorability
donald trump
now has 31 percent favorability in the
united states
and he went into the republican national
convention with 32 percent favorability
now what's really important to remember
about that
is that there are many people who have
an unfavorable view of trump
and are still going to vote for him much
like there are people
who have an unfavorable view of joe
biden but are going to vote for him
because they
accurately recognize that he's a better
choice than donald trump so even though
trump's favorability is in the low 30s
donald trump is certainly going to get
40 something percent of the popular vote
in november and exactly where
in the 40s he falls is going to
determine whether he gets reelected or
not
if we look at the internals of this
favorability decline
trump's favorability during the
convention or
since the convention dropped four points
among republicans so republicans were
were
particularly not thrilled with what they
saw
during the convention on individual
issues
coronavirus continues to be a big
problem for trump
where 63 percent of americans disapprove
of his handling
and then just for comparison joe biden's
favorability went
up six points from pre to post
convention
40 to 46 percent now it's still not
great and this is one of the reasons why
if you want to compare this election to
one
from times past you look at 2016 where
you had two candidates
in 2016 it was hillary clinton and
donald trump in 2020 you have joe biden
and donald trump
neither of whom has 50 favorability now
the difference between biden at 46 and
trump at 31
is significant but of course it's
ultimately going to come down
to a handful you know five to eight or
so
battleground states and we're going to
talk about that in a little bit now
in terms of who watched the convention
we talked last week in the week before
during the convention coverage
about who is this really for
we learned that 72 percent
watched very little or none of the
conventions
so it continues to be clear that voters
who watched
a lot of the conventions over the last
couple of weeks
are voters who are already definitely
voting in other words they were
definitely voting even before the
conventions
started they weren't convinced to vote
by the conventions and number two
are almost certainly already decided and
that is an important thing to think
about in terms
of the reviews of the conventions when
donald trump brags that his speech was
very well reviewed
or someone else says trump's speech was
bad or biden was good or whatever the
case may be
most people who watch these conventions
are already very much decided and a lot
of people are simply not watching them
at all so what really matters
is for us to step back and look at the
trends if you look at one trend
like the gallup presidential approval
tracking poll
interesting there that donald trump has
never
hit 50 percent approval on even
one sampling of the gallup presidential
approval
tracking poll during his entire
presidency donald trump
never hit 50 but
half the country does not vote which
means that even without 50
approval even without 35 percent
favorability
donald trump can still win inaction
not voting is an action it has an effect
and it has never never been more
dangerous than it is right now
in many swing states donald trump is
doing okay shockingly if you're paying
attention to what's going on
you should be shocked by this in many
swing states
donald trump's approval on coronavirus
has actually started to tick up
even if it's still one of the biggest
areas of liability for donald trump
nationally so when we talk about
if trump wins what will it mean yeah it
will mean that there are lots of
easily manipulable people
in the country it will mean that there
are lots of cognitively compromised
people
but democrats are going to have some
responsibility to bear i mean if
democrats lose this with trump at 31
approval you can't just blame trumpists
for being dumb that would be a complete
lack of self-awareness it would
partially be the inability to control
the narrative against donald trump
the inability to actually put together
uh
it doesn't even have to be perfect
messaging just good enough messaging to
beat someone whose
31 favorability rating is historically
low
get out the vote will have been a
failing for sure because we know that
non-voters from 2016 overwhelmingly
favor joe biden
if you can't get them to vote you're
going to have some responsibility to
bear as well
so there are lots of elements of this
feeling like 2016
and when you look at these numbers when
you look at the polling data i looked at
with you last week
the last thing any of us should be doing
is thinking joe biden's got this in the
bag it's not reverse gas lighting
it's not concerned trolling it's looking
a lot like 2016
in many ways hopefully it ends up
differently
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
just because an idea is bad doesn't mean
that it won't continue to get more and
more
oxygen and become more and more
prevalent if it's politically
advantageous or serve somebody's
political interests and we are seeing
the very strong return of the idea of
pushing for herd immunity when it comes
to coronavirus in the united states from
the trump administration donald trump
has brought on a new
i i guess he's calling him a coronavirus
advisor his name is scott atlas now the
guy is a doctor
but he's really more of a political
figure than a medical figure because he
is a neuroradiologist which as you might
notice does not have very much to do
with infectious disease and
pandemic science but he is a part of the
conservative think st
think tank the hoover institution and
he's increasingly talking about going in
the direction of the sweden model and
even beyond into the herd immunity
bottle and there's a lot to talk about
here
i want to make sure everybody
understands why this is so
pernicious and dangerous so herd
immunity
is the idea that once enough of your
population of a population
is immune to a disease you have
a sort of group resistance to it enough
people
are immune that it is unlikely
that the reproduction rate of the
disease is going to
become high enough to create a pandemic
type situation because there aren't just
there just aren't going to be enough
people left in the population
susceptible to the disease now
typically the way in the modern
human era we achieve herd immunity
is through vaccination if you vaccinate
a large swath of the population
that's how you generate herd immunity
you're not typically generating it
through
people just getting sick and recovering
naturally now depending on how
contagious a disease
is the percentage of the population that
needs to be immune
varies so for example we're putting up
on the screen sort of a
scale of diseases of different levels of
contagion if you look at
measles measles is so contagious it has
a reproduction rate between 12 and 18
that in order to get herd immunity you
need
somewhere between 92 and 95 of the
population
to be immune either through having
recovered from the disease
uh or vaccination or usually it's a
combination of the two
if you look sort of in the middle you've
got mumps
mumps has a reproduction rate an r
naught of four to seven
so because it's less contagious than
measles you need somewhere between
75 and 86 of the population
to be immune to get hurt immunity and as
you can see
if you're looking at this chart
coronavirus
is estimated to have a reproduction rate
of somewhere between
two and six meaning that somewhere
between
50 and 83 of the population
need immunity for us to have what we
would call
herd immunity so that brings us to this
neuroradiologist scott atlas who donald
trump has brought in and he's cheering
and saying it's so great to have scott
involved
what he wants is more of the sweden
model
and more of a push for herd immunity as
a way to get beyond
coronavirus and the pandemic the numbers
if you think about them
are really really ugly so i told you
that we
for coronavirus to reach herd immunity
we need between 50 and 83
of the population to be immune let's
just pick a number that's right
in the middle there okay we'll call it
67 percent for
just to pick a number uh let's assume
for a second
remember we have to assume that
recovering from the virus gives you
immunity
for a significant period of time we're
still trying to figure that out
and number two let's even assume
officially we've had 6.1 million cases
in the united states
let's imagine we've really had twice as
many okay
let's imagine we've only found
officially
half of the cases so even though the
official number is six
let's imagine we've had 12 million cases
in the united states
with 331 million people in this country
if we've had 12 million cases that means
right now
3.6 percent of the population
is immune presumably if nobody gets the
vaccine
in order to get to herd immunity which
means 67 percent of the population
that would be 222 million cases right
two-thirds
of 331 million is 222.
if you understand that we have about a
one percent death rate
that means that to get to herd immunity
the u.s would suffer
2.2 million deaths
so far only 187
000 have died an unconscionable number
but less than 10 percent of what we
would expect
if we were to go to herd immunity
without a vaccine
so that would mean that if we do what
scott atlas
wants and the other herd immunity
advocates
we still have two million deaths to come
now what might change that number
if we get really good at treating the
virus
and we can reduce the death rate for
example from one percent to 0.5 percent
then we would have one million more
people die
on the way to herd immunity now the
problem is that there's another side to
that
which is if we have this many cases
over a relatively short period of time
because we just open it back up and let
it rip
the hospitals will become overloaded and
what we do know is that the death rate
goes up when hospitals get
very very full so this is sort of again
going back to this
we've really tried nothing yet and we're
out of ideas
we've not really had a coordinated
national lockdown we never really did
a six-week serious shutdown and now
we're heading
into flu season and what many infectious
disease doctors
expect to be at this point calling it a
second wave doesn't even make sense
because we've never really gotten down
below
30 000 cases a day for months and months
but this is the approach that they now
have now on the other side
remember nobody's calling for a forever
shutdown or forever closures or anything
what we're talking about right now in a
modestly optimistic scenario
is another few months
we expect some vaccine to be approved in
the next couple of months we expect it
to start being available by the end of
the year
we expect that it will be reasonably
affected
and we expect that most of the
population in the u.s
who wants the vaccine which is a whole
other problem
is going to be able to get it by the
start of the spring of 2021 that may
change
but does nobody understand delayed
gratification here we are getting closer
and the approach that donald trump
increasingly wants to take of pretending
that this is basically in the rear view
mirror
while pushing for herd immunity through
some of his followers
and staff is a very dangerous idea and
the simple numbers explain why
hey um donald trump almost fell
flat on his face at a recent rally in
londonderry new hampshire
again raising questions about donald
trump's
balance and other uh supposed symptoms
that could connect
to cognitive decline or frontotemporal
dementia or other conditions that there
there are discussions of donald trump
having but even before we get to that
donald trump is now just having rallies
he's having rallies as if there is no
pandemic
he had 1500 or so people at his
rnc speech no masks no
testing no social distancing and
not only was the rhetoric of the rnc
indicative of a pandemic that's in the
rearview mirror
the actions were as well and donald
trump now
is simply resuming rallies large rallies
rallies without social distancing and
rallies of course
with uh some arrests uh
a number of different arrests taking
place
after donald trump's londonderry new
hampshire rally but first and foremost
so here is donald trump
uh walking up a set of stairs
to give his speech and as you can see
donald trump uh sort of losing his
balance
and just narrowly avoiding falling flat
on his face and of course as people
watch this
a lot of speculation about donald
trump's balance and fitness
we all remember donald trump being
helped down
a ramp when he spoke at west point just
a few months ago
speculation about cognitive decline uh
all of these questions continuing to run
rampant and certainly donald trump
almost falling down it certainly could
be nothing i'll be the first to tell you
it could just be
a bad bad set of circumstances uh taking
a wrong step or whatever
but certainly with everything else
that's been going on with donald trump
bragging about his great score on a
cognitive test meant only to
identify very serious signs of cognitive
decline dementia etc
not particularly inspiring of confidence
now once
trump got on the stage it didn't
actually get any better donald trump
ranting and raving about all sorts of
bizarre things another one of these just
humiliating events
that really is as much of an indictment
of the crowd who will clap
for anything at this point as much of an
indictment of the the supporters
as it is of donald trump here is donald
trump with a very
strange rant about protesting
ass you're not mishearing me talking
about
his ass this is the president ladies and
gentlemen making no sense
you know what i say protest is your ass
i don't talk about my ass
so this is an extremely low level of
discourse
it's a crowd that will cheer for
anything i i don't really like this term
i think it's one of these stupid terms
that
trumpists latched onto for a little
while but the idea of the
npc a non-playable character from a
video game
that just repeats the predictable
pre-programmed actions no matter what's
going on around them
that's what i think of thanks to
trumpists who introduced me to the term
that's what i think of when i see people
clapping for anything that donald trump
says
later in the rally donald trump said
people have no choice
but to vote for him and that he really
doesn't have to be
running for president anyway i guess he
is continuing to say that this is a
favor he's done the american people i
guess take a look
job every family and every neighborhood
and we will fight for every vote we have
to win we have no choice
can i be honest with you okay look we're
working hard we're all working i don't
have to do this
i could get off that beautiful plane it
used to be black and white
with a red stripe that was mine
but that's air force one you know i get
off that beautiful plane
i could come up and say ladies and
gentlemen of new hampshire you have no
choice you have to
vote for me because if you don't you'll
be put in radical lefties you'll have a
depression
now of course remember we have an
economic
uh uh recession depression
now under democrats these are just the
facts we could debate how much they
matter we can debate correlation versus
causation but if you look historically
under democratic presidents stocks do
better but stocks aren't really
an indicator of the economy at large
unemployment is lower under democratic
presidents
gdp growth is higher under democratic
presidents
job creation is stronger under
democratic presidents
you can argue correctly that on too many
issues
there are not real substantive
differences
between your average democrat and your
average republican that's a fair
discussion to have but these numbers are
clear so the fear-mongering
that the stock market will implode if
joe biden is president
that the economy will implode that your
401ks will be worth nothing that
unemployment will explode that taxes
will quadruple
none of it is borne out by the by the
facts
another example by the way of how easily
the trump crowd will just do whatever
trump says
trump attacking or mentioning chris
wallace from fox news
the crowd booing they will at the drop
of a hat
turn on whoever take a look at this and
one person i think was chris wallace
nice guy he's actually a nice guy
he said that uh he didn't have the same
energy in the speech that he usually has
well it's a different kind of a speech
tonight i'm in new hampshire and we can
wing it
so notice how donald trump's entire base
i mean for for years
fox news was their friend fox news was
their ally and mostly fox news still
carries water for donald trump
but notice how quickly the entire base
turns on whoever including fox news
this is a sign of a cult that what the
leader
says is not questioned and adhered to we
spoke to cult expert stephen hassan a
few months ago
and it was one of the signs that he
talked about and then lastly donald
trump
insisting that the protesters aren't
protesters
and they don't even know why they're
protesting
they're not protesters those aren't
those are anarchists they're agitators
they're rioters they're looters they're
not you know you say that
and some of the people not all of them
but some of the people back there oh
i do how dare you these are friendly
protesters right
friendly proctor
they're just looking for trouble has
nothing to do with george floyd has
nothing to do with anything they don't
even know who george floyd is
okay they don't know who george they
have no idea
if you ask them who's george floyd they
couldn't even tell you
these are just bad people trouble makers
and they shouldn't be representing our
country
at important events and we've got to
stop it
so we're going to talk about the
protests
the inciting to violence of protesters
by the trump administration
in more detail later on in the program
but
what you have here fundamentally is
hostility towards people exercising
their rights under the first amendment
in a way that donald trump doesn't like
that's what this
is and i'm going to talk later i don't
want to get ahead of myself
of why inciting them to violence
is beneficial for donald trump's
reelection campaign that's coming up
later
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show for more
on this
and all of the other stories from
today's show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
so we have uh continued protests
and growing unrest in different parts of
the country and i'm really going to
focus in today
on the political implications
particularly when we have
just you know about eight weeks left
until a presidential election that
hinges significantly on the idea
of do we need another four years like
the last four
or do we need something different that's
the context that we should be applying
to the upcoming election and so in
portland oregon
we saw a pro-trump mob drive
through the city one person was shot
dead
we've seen clashes involving mace spray
and paintball guns we saw trucks firing
projectiles
into crowds and driving into people
here's a video of pickup trucks with
trump flags
and american frat flags uh pepper
spraying people
and driving into individuals a union
building
was set on fire here's video of trump
people
shooting paintballs and pepper spray at
other individuals who were protesting
and just absolute complete and total
chaos ensuing
and there's a couple different layers of
this that we should really discuss
the first is what are the realities and
the facts
about the protests themselves and then
the political impact which i think is
far more relevant and and actually it's
something we can discuss in much more
tangible terms
even though the the political impact is
more
speculative than the facts on the ground
i would argue
it's actually a much simpler and more
straightforward conversation to have
so the first thing is in terms of the
the realities like what is happening
in different cities cities are being
uh uh filled up with trump
people and protesters who are protesting
uh police brutality uh black lives
matter protesters
etc donald trump is insisting
he needs to be re-elected to stop the
chaos in cities
that doesn't pass the sniff test and
we're going to talk about
that but before we do that i i think it
makes sense for us to
maybe get on the same page about
what are the conversations that we
should be having online
on social media and which conversation
should we probably skip
and a lot of the debates are over what
portion of the unrest is coming from the
left
and what portion of the unrest is coming
from the right
and i'll tell you it's completely
fraught to go down
that road and what i mean by that is the
following
if the violence that we're seeing not
protesting protesting is
for you know protected by the first
amendment and the protesting
is not the problem although some people
will tell you it is if the violence
was 95 trump people
and 5 black lives matter or
if the violence was 95 black lives
matter
and 5 trump people it really doesn't
make a difference
in terms of the political impact and
it's a debate
that you will never be able to get
agreement on
and people are going to be focusing only
on that
the unfortunate reality is that more
chaos and more violence helps donald
trump and i know that there are some
people on the left who disagree with me
on this
there are some people on the left who
are insisting wait a second
people will see violence under donald
trump
and they will blame trump at least
partially for the violence it's
counterintuitive
trump is president now and there's chaos
now how does violence and unrest help
donald trump
the narrative has been lost and remember
half the country doesn't vote and so a
lot of this is who do you
get to go and vote okay now
in that context chaos in the streets
favors the person supported by the
military gun types
regardless of whether it makes any sense
i hate that this is the reality i really
do
trump seems to realize it and later in
the program i'll talk to you about how
kellyanne conway
is admitting it and the more
chaos there is either way
it's beneficial to donald trump unless
we really turn the vote out now again
i'm getting uh when i've been tweeting
about this including over the weekend
people write to me and they say david
you're wrong people see
violence under trump's watch and it
hurts him
i do not believe that that is correct
the chaos activates trump's base
this idea of dangerous democrat cities
has been effective for activating donald
trump's
base and again the election
will be influenced by people who change
their minds but it's
mostly check out my interview with
rachel bittikoffer it's mostly going to
be a reflection
of who is activated and who chooses to
go out and vote
the framing from trump of course
is that it's mostly violence by black
lives matter
against white people trump supporters
whatever
the unfortunate reality is that that's
the wrong
area to be focusing the debate because
imagine
that we get out there successfully
the narrative that it's not mostly
violence from black lives matter
it's mostly violence from trumpists well
then they'll just say well yeah the
trumpists have have to be out there
because there's chaos in the streets
you saw it with kyle rittenhouse now
there's the debate oh well kyle
rittenhouse
he was actually didn't bring the gun
across state lines somebody gave him the
gun in wisconsin
oh well kyle rittenhouse was filmed two
weeks ago sucker punching a girl so
it when you start making the debate
about that you get lost in the weeds and
the unfortunate reality is that trump
benefits on this no matter what i hate
to say it
because it activates certain people it
pushes certain buttons
for lack of a better term if it's
chaotic
people might be less likely to want to
change horses midstream
if trump stops the violence he will take
credit and get it from some of the
people who would be predisposed
to be open to that type of idea if trump
sends in the troops
it activates his base it's a real sort
of
rorschach test or an ink blot of
possibilities
and the next thing i want to talk about
is kellyanne conway straight up
admitting this
and also talking more about the dynamics
of why this is beneficial to donald
trump
okay so we already talked a little bit
about the unrest that we saw over the
weekend
in different cities across the country
clashes everything from pepper spray
trump trucks with flags driving into
people i mean we just saw all sorts of
different stuff and the point i tried to
make
was that arguing about what percentage
of the unrest and violence is coming
from
from either side from each side is not
really an effective use of time and that
even though it's counter-intuitive i
believe that chaos and unrest
helps donald trump secure re-election if
it does anything at all
well outgoing trump advisor kellyanne
conway
was recently interviewed and she said
that from her perspective the more chaos
there is
she used the words anarchy and vandalism
the better it is and in terms
of the choice between trump and biden
on public safety and law and order now i
happen to agree with her
i think she's completely wrong on the
facts in other words
trump's president now and the chaos he's
pointing to is happening now
that doesn't really justify re-electing
trump so i disagree with her that it
actually illuminates who would be better
on this issue
vice vice president joe biden was vice
president for eight years we didn't have
this type of chaos then but from a
political standpoint
and in terms of who supports which
candidate i believe she is right let's
take a look at what she had to say
also notice there was a quote today from
a restaurateur in wisconsin
saying are you protesters trying to get
donald trump reelected
he knows full stop and i guess mayor
pete knows full stop
that the more chaos and anarchy and
vandalism and violence reigns
the better it is for the very clear
choice on who's best on public safety
and law order one of the i was in fort
mchenry last so
a logical person would say wait wait a
second
trump is president and it's chaotic you
don't expect
that same president to fix the issue you
change president if you want the issue
fixed re-electing the guy
during whom during whose presidency
there's chaos
isn't going to stop the chaos the
reality is
that they are creating these images
of chaos with footage from portland it's
being strategically disseminated
you know look at some of the usual
suspects some of the so-called
enlightened centrists on the internet
who claim to be unbiased arbiters but
who are furthering this exact narrative
that things would be far less chaotic if
trump gets re-elected
they use this to rile up their base
trump has been doing it
for a while we saw it during the rnc
using the phrase
violent anarchists or anarchists as
trump often says mispronouncing it
marxists they talk about socialist
communists etc
who are out there and they want to hurt
the police and they want to hurt people
and all of this different stuff
this is called chaos pr chaos public
relations
and it is counter-intuitive i get that
it's counter-intuitive and i understand
why some in the audience don't agree
with me vladimir putin has used this
stuff
um benjamin netanyahu in israel
previously
previously used more what we would call
fear public relations than chaos public
public relations but it's certainly
related and the idea
is that when you're let me let me see
how i can explain this
in the clearest way when your
um uh pop when your constituents
are the ones more likely to be activated
by
chaos the fact that the chaos is
happening under your watch doesn't hurt
you
and if there are a whole bunch of people
remember half the country doesn't vote
but there are a bunch of people in the
non-voters who would support
biden if they voted and there's a whole
bunch of people in the non-voters who
would support
trump if they voted if you can find an
issue
that disproportionately activates your
side
it really doesn't matter if it's idiotic
to suggest
that hey it's chaotic under my watch
re-elect me and i'll stop the chaos
the lack of logic in that actually
doesn't matter
the biden campaign is increasingly
understanding this trump's
biden's deputy campaign manager kate
bettingfield
said over the weekend trump is
deliberately
inciting violence and i believe he is
because he believes it will benefit him
the united states globally has become a
joke under this presidency
and donald trump is doing something that
should be laughed
out of office which is trying to get
reelected
by gaslighting people about the current
state of affairs
trump had a failed coronavirus response
it caused chaos
it cost medical chaos cultural chaos
economic chaos
trump then blames the chaos on the left
and says re-elect me and i'll fix this
wait a second you caused it
trump is essentially trying to be both
the arsonist and the fireman
right create the crisis and present
himself as the hero who can fix it and
to that
end he is manipulating the bases of both
parties and getting the bases of both
parties to play active roles
understand the i don't want to call it
genius because i don't know that it's
calculated
but what donald trump is doing by
inciting violence and unrest
is he's activating the so-called law and
order people on his side to get out and
vote
and he's also activating the people on
the left
who are furious about what's going on to
go and protest
and while most of the protesters are
overwhelmingly peaceful
it is going to foment the narrative
that he wants of an angry out of control
anarchist left which is not accurate but
it is
doing things to both bases that i
believe benefits him now unfortunately
fact checking this won't help
we've been fact checking it for a long
time it's beyond fact checking
and to i i'm assuming i don't have to
say this to you
when the incumbent president believes
that generating more chaos in the
streets retweeting videos of
street fights as trump did over the
weekend which i will tell you about
uh it is not a good situation when that
is what the incumbent president believes
will get him re-elected
it's even worse when he might be right
um
and of course this strategy
disproportionately works on people who
can easily be bamboozled there are a lot
of those people
in trump's constituency so the question
is what should we do
i don't have an answer for you today i'm
going to think about it
and hopefully follow up with you later
this week if you have thoughts i do want
to hear from you you can let me know
via twitter deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay so we already discussed earlier and
i mentioned to you that a man was killed
in portland oregon
over the weekend and this as well as
some of the other events of the weekend
despite not stopping donald trump from
golfing did set him off
tweeting completely uncontrollably for
hours
in the middle of the night and these
really were
the rantings of a madman and they're
you know it's it's not normal for
anybody to behave this way on social
media
it's not normal for anybody to be
tweeting this much on social media
most people don't have this much time to
be spending so much time tweeting and
retweeting things
on social media and i mean listen when
when i see someone tweeting at messages
at me so frequently i just mute them
immediately and we have the president
doing this and each of these tweets
we're going to look at
are so riddled with lies we could
analyze all of them in detail
i'm only going to do a couple many of
these are sort of illuminating or
informative in some way i think there's
something we can
we can get from them um so one of the
questions
that has been coming up is why isn't joe
biden criticizing the violence and
unrest
in the streets and of course he has but
donald didn't really matter to donald
trump donald trump tweeting quote
when is slow joe biden going to critic
criticize the anarchists thugs and
agitators
in antifa when is he going remember
antifa hasn't killed anyone
when is he going to suggest bringing up
the national guard
in badly run and crime infested democrat
cities and states
remember he can't lose the crazy bernie
super liberal vote well biden did
actually do that denouncing and it's
trump who has refused to denounce
some of the individuals and some of the
violence that has actually taken place
over the last four days joe joe biden
put out a statement about this
and in that statement he said quote i
condemn
this violence unequivocally
i condemn violence of every kind by
anyone
whether on the left or the right and i
challenge donald trump to do the same
well trump hasn't
it does not matter if you find the
political views
of your opponents abhorrent any loss of
life is a tragedy
today there is another family grieving
in america
and jill and i offer our deepest
condolences but it doesn't matter to
trump
it's the narrative that biden won't
denounce it and things will be even
crazier if biden is president
and it's working on a bunch of people
trump also had a two-tweet rant about
joe biden
we'll go through some of the lies here
joe biden is coming out of the basement
earlier than his hoped for 10 days
because his people told him he has no
choice his poll numbers are plunging now
that's not true
there is a tightening in some areas but
biden's numbers aren't plunging
trump goes on going to pittsburgh where
i have helped industry to a record last
year that's a lie
and then back to his basement for an
extended period his problem is
interesting he must always be weak on
crime
because of the bernie sanders radical
left voter
what's amazing on this is that one of
the primary critiques from the bernie
left about biden
is his involvement in the 1990s crime
bill which even though it was almost 30
years ago
still is mentioned as biden being too
much like a republican
on supposed law and order and crime but
in any case you can't talk sense into
these people
trump going on if he loses them like
crooked hillary did he is toast
and many will vote for me because of
trade
bernie was good on trade joe must
always be weak on crime so
this is now you know the basement stuff
continues and the joe biden is weak
stuff is continuing but it's also
completely disconnected from what joe
biden is actually doing joe biden
actually
has been more visible lately joe biden
is going to be
speaking in a few places joe biden's rnc
speech
dnc speech rather compared to trump's
rnc speech was
tethered to reality unremarkable but
completely reasonable
trump then going on to tweet the only
way you will stop the violence
in the high crime democrat-run cities
is through strength now remember
whatever violence is going on now
is going on now when trump is president
and trump insisting that to stop the
violence
that's happening during his presidency
you need to reelect him
doesn't pass the sniff test but as i
talked about in the last segment
the chaos helps trump big picture
that's scary trump also retweeting a
bunch of different
fight videos believe it or not this is
the president of the united states
trump also tweeting attacks on different
people for example tweeting
ted wheeler the wacky radical
left-do-nothing democrat mayor of
portland
who has watched great death and
destruction of his city during his
tenure
thinks this lawless situation should go
on forever
wrong portland will never recover
with a fool for a mayor remember
trump is president now if trump can stop
the violence
why isn't trump stopping the violence or
saying he won't do it
until he's re-elected very very
disturbing
that that is not raising a red flag with
tens of millions of trump voters
trump also tweeting law and order
in all capital letters multiple times
over the weekend
hundreds of tweets and retweets
outrageous behavior from a sitting
president of the united states
we have a really crazy situation in the
united states
where because of the mishandling of
coronavirus by the president
americans are trapped in the united
states
now this applies to health care
as many of you probably know it's common
that americans will go to canada for
insulin where
it can be obtained much less expensively
it's common that americans
along the southern border will go to
mexico for eye
and dental care i've shown these maps
before but if you look for example
at the mexican uh town small city
of los algodones you see that it is just
filled with eye and dental clinics why
is this it's because americans cross the
border
to get high quality affordable eye and
dental care
except that now because of coronavirus
americans are allowed almost nowhere
around the world we have a health care
system
that is such a fiasco that regularly
people will escape the united states for
medical treatment well now they can't
in addition to just medical treatment
many people leave the united states for
education to go someplace where
college is less expensive that's
increasingly difficult to do
now with coronavirus i have friends who
have figured it out who for example
they want to be in europe to get away
from what's going on europe is not
most countries are not allowing
americans in so they go to the uk
where you can quarantine for 14 days if
coming from the u.s then you're in
and you can travel to other european
countries
but this is really a major issue more
than 2 million americans regularly buy
prescriptions abroad
that's mostly canada and mexico and
somehow
our horrible health care system has been
made even worse
by restricting the ability of americans
to essentially
flee to other countries with more
affordable health care and you still
have people
who don't recognize that we need
dramatic and drastic systemic change to
the american health care system now
if you want to go beyond medical uh
we've become the world pariah
we were the laughingstock we now are the
pity of the world
and people are also angry at the
irresponsibility
of what's going on in the united states
and you know i mentioned a few weeks ago
it has occurred to me to just get out of
the u.s
in the fall for what will likely be a
very difficult public health situation
and part of the reason that has held me
back from confirming those plans
is i am not that interested in being
seen
in other parts of the world as the
irresponsible americans
who were just traveling around and
potentially spreading coronavirus
obviously i would be careful i would
wear a mask i would get a test
i would quarantine i would do all of
that stuff but but i don't want to be
seen that way so
donald trump's cult has gotten what they
wanted they've essentially gotten close
borders we've closed
many of our borders from people coming
in although that's starting to loosen
because let's be honest the problem is
increasingly here not in other countries
and the united states
is now on a blacklist in most parts
of the world it's only taken 187 000
dead
in order to get those borders closed so
that americans increasingly can't leave
the united states now just as a reminder
on health care
back in july donald trump told chris
wallace during that interview
within two weeks we'll sign a new health
care plan
into law never happened then trump said
it would be done by the end of august
well that's today it's not going to
happen every single day
trump should be pressed on that because
it is yet another one of those failed
broken promises unfortunately and this
really is horrible for us and i know
you know people write to me from all
over the world who who watch the program
and they feel bad mostly
the us is feeling more and more like
gilead the uh
world described by margaret atwood
in her two novels handmaid's tale and
more recently the sequel
testaments it's very bad it is very very
bad
americans trapped in the united states
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
this is a really funny voicemail um
see if you can pick up on what's funny
about it take a listen
hey dave i was just wondering they want
to get
trump out of there what happened to the
21st
amendment right not for office
yeah this is so funny so the 25th
amendment provides a mechanism for
removing donald trump or any president
for being
unfit hilariously the caller mentions
the 21st amendment
which ended prohibition which was put in
place by the 18th amendment
so i know i'm sort of kidding around i
know the caller means the 25th amendment
but i actually started thinking
is there any way we could use the 21st
amendment to justify removing donald
trump i can't think offhand of how we
would do it
but a funny idea but no it is the 25th
amendment that could be used
it will not be used donald trump's
cabinet has no interest in removing him
no matter how clearly unfit for office
he is we will have a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about whether
it is
fair to blame college parties
for the spread of coronavirus or not we
will also talk about
second amendment sanctuary cities you
may or may not have heard of that
and we will also talk about an
interesting shift within the american
military
the american military now members of the
military expected to vote
for joe biden over donald trump that is
not the way
things usually go in history with the
military vote so all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just fifteen minutes you can try
blinkist for free
and save twenty five percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash david
pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video